hey what is up this is John Maloney with
Ramsey Network we are taking your ass
John and Ramsey solutions calm emails
today we've got some more awesome ones
here we go
let's party so I'm gonna call this dude
an I hope that's not Dan's real name
sorry Dan of a troll name I didn't put
his real name on the email dr. de Loney
you've been such a calming blessing in
these times thank you for joining the
Ramsey team thank you big things today
if he pays me it's all working out good
I'm a man in my mid 30s married to the
most kind peaceful loving woman I've
ever known
she is always the peacemaker I can be
pretty pigheaded and easily irritated at
times and I feel ashamed that I haven't
grown up in that way yet we are both on
our second marriage and we have a little
boy on the way August 1st the first kid
for both of us some of these negative
character issues stem from watching my
parents growing up and then cementing
them through my own bonehead choices I
never want to make my wife feel small
again and I never want my son to see me
mistreat her where do I start to leave
these things behind thank you for your
help
number one Dan thanks for having the
courage to type this out most dudes
especially pigheaded dudes are too proud
and too tough and too like you know
what's up let's do a CrossFit WOD to
actually sit down and say hey I'm
hurting my wife I don't want to get
better thank you for doing that
number two thanks for being willing to
give us another shot a second time and
to say hey I screwed this up the first
time I want to make it better
kudos to you Dan all right number three
your parents gave you a bad model cool
but appeared at the end of that sentence
never mention it again
it's a context not an excuse okay we
often live into the the picture that our
parents gave us right I do dad like my
dad did dad because that's what I know
dads do and my wife does wife the way
she saw her mom do wife and so we have
to learn together and we have to
communicate when we've given the
negative patterns we realize where they
came from that's awesome but we can't
carry that stuff around so we're gonna
stop from this point forward and we're
gonna live this way not looking back at
what mom and dad gave us all right so
you said that you did not want to make
your wife feel small again you don't
want your wife to have to play the
peacemaker again
that is a role so often that men squish
and compress women into is this idea
that they've got to always be worrying
about everybody else's feelings instead
of an instead of being able to be their
authentic true self so you want to stop
making your wife feel small this side
I'm gonna stop making my wife feel small
that's it now I know that sounds simple
and trite and cheesy but decide to not
make her feel small again
because here's the deal when I hear a
dude tell me that they're being
irritable or they're being pigheaded and
they're in their mid-30s that screams
male depression to me because most men
do not have the skills or the the
ability to talk to communicate to say
hey this is how I'm feeling about things
they know - two things one puffs their
chest out in the cart core or to getting
a recliner and play video games
hide write puff your chest up high
that's how men handle that kind of stuff
so the key for you is this when you feel
yourself about to be a jerk when you
feel yourself about to snap or be
irritable that's when you have to stop
you stop yourself and say what is my
brain trying to protect me from right
now because it doesn't happen
accidentally but it does happen
automatically
and so you walk into a room and the
rooms of mass and you were expecting
dinner on the stove or whatever the
thing is in your world and it starts
building that's your body releasing
those hormones right those fight flight
or freeze hormones those stress hormones
that anger that heywhat something in
here isn't how I thought it was gonna be
the picture was about to see is
different than what I thought it was
gonna be now you got a choice right then
daq like a baby act like a child throw a
temper tantrum throw a fit again like
you said like you saw happen or realize
this picture is different than the one
you had in mind that's cool
if I need to have a conversation about
my wife and I our pictures are different
we're gonna do it at a neutral site
right out of the emotions out of the
frustration out of the anger but you get
to decide right now what are my thoughts
and actions gonna be your thoughts can
be a my wife is lazy again she's not
doing anything I'm out working so hard
or they can be mad I bet she worked her
butt off to that but that it was hard I
can't wait to sit on the figure
how hard things were for her and what I
can do to decrease the stress and the
anxiety in her world how can I bring
that down for those are your two choices
you got you can choose one you can
choose two you emailed me to figure it
out so here's a couple of things you can
do number one you can do SOS
skin-on-skin that brings down
everybody's fight or flight or freeze
stress response right that doesn't have
to be sexual looking me holding hands
that can be touching feet when you wake
up in the morning that can just be hugs
right so I'd recommend four times a day
three times a day right when you wake up
right before you leave work right when
you get home right before you go to bed
if it ends up being sexual touch
intimacy time good good and grand but
really what you're trying to do is just
connect with somebody right number two
gratitude every day Dan I want you to
write five things that start with the
sentence I am grateful for about my wife
fill it in I'm grateful that she XYZ I'm
grateful that she ABC I'm grateful that
she one two three and do it every single
day and the last thing I want y'all to
go get a marriage counselor and I want
you to initiate it and I want you to
take your wife out to dinner I don't
want you to tell her I messed up during
my first marriage it didn't go like I
wanted it to go and I want to do better
this time and I recognize I'm already
running over you I'm already forcing you
into position of being the peacemaker
around here dealing with my brattiness
my childhood nonsense
and I want to be better and I want to
change and so I'm asking you to go with
me to a marriage counselor so I can work
on the things I need to work on don't
talk about things she needs to work on
you talk about the things you need to
work on and I don't know a wife on
planet earth that won't respond
positively to that but if that does
happen to me your wife
so to email me and ask John at Ramsey
solutions calm and we'll answer her
email here too
thank you so much this has been dr. de
Loney and I will talk to you later
subscribe press the buttons follow me at
John de Loney and I'll see you soon bye
bye